bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat faut-il supprimer le
dél de racolage passif c'est la question
que se sont posé hier les sénateurs en
séance publique à l'occasion de l'examen
d'une proposition de loi de la sénatrice
écologiste Esther Benbassa elle propose
simplement et bien de supprimer ce dél
de racolage qui depuis la loi de 2003
sur la sécurité intérieure était puni de
2 mois d'emprisonnement et de 3750 €
d'amende jusqu'à présent c'est le
racolage actif qui était sanctionné par
une contravention alors sans plus tardé
direction l'hémicycle du Sénat bonne
matinée à tous l'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à l'abrogation du délis de
racolage public présenté par Madame Eser
Benbassa et plusieurs de ses collègue à
la demande du groupe
écologiste je tiens à vous rappeler que
nous sommes dans un temps contraint donc
nous démarrons là à
16h30 nous en avons donc jusqu'à 20h30
je tenais à le rappeler pour que il n'y
ait
aucun ah oui très bien non non c'est 4h
c'est
4h on peut pas faire autrement je peux
par je ne peux pas augmenter le temps
donc essayons de tenir jusqu'à 20h15 on
verra ça serait mieux voilà voilà nous
allons essayer je demande alors des
efforts collectifs merci monsieur le
Président dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Esther Benbassa
auteur de la proposition de
loi madame la
Présidente
madame la
Présidente Mesdames les ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'histoire de la prostitution
et de ses perceptions dans une société
est aussi celle des pudeurs de cette
société de ses occultations de ses
transgressions et de ses violence en ce
domaine comme en d'autres la France est
évidemment tributaire de son histoire
c'est vers 1800 au lendemain d'une
révolution marquée par des appels
sporadiques en faveur d'une
libéralisation des mœurs que le consulat
inaugure une politique cohérente qui
marque le siècle et demi suivant la
conviction domine que légiférer en
matière de prostitution reviendrait à
salir le lé lislateur mais une autre
s'impose dans le même temps il y aurait
nécessité de mettre de l'ordre dans le
commerce sexuel de le surveiller
d'éclairer de la lumière purificatrice
du pouvoir l'univers obscur de la
vénalité c'est ce qui conduit à
soumettre la prostitution à un règlement
est dicté sur une base municipal d'abord
à Paris ainsi est né ce qu'on va appeler
le règle lementarisme appelé French
system dans d'autres pays bien sûr dans
les pays qui l'ont imité fondé sur une
doctrine philosophique du mal nécessaire
elle-même inspiré d'Augustin ce Père de
l'Église du 4e siècle jugeait les
prostituées
méprisables mais il était aussi
convaincu que si on les supprimer les
passions bouleverseraient le
monde cette réflexion d'ordre moral qui
guida l'action des auteurs de règlement
n'a pas cessé de hanter les esprits
d'aujourd'hui les auteurs des règlements
avaient toutefois une autre antise la
menace sanitaire qui pesa de tout son
poids pour la mise en place des maisons
clauses et c'est bien la fermeture de
ces dernières imposé par la loi du 13
avril
1946 dite Mart Richard qui mit un terme
à l'air réglementation
l'histoire de la prostitution en France
n'est pourtant pas seulement du
réglementarisme fascination et rejet s'y
renforce mutuellement au début de la 3e
république sous le gouvernement d'ordre
moral d'Albert de Bry sous la présidence
de mcmaon la question de la prostitution
émerge d'une manière aigue
ususmans Edmond de goncour Zola publie
des romans qui la prennent pour thème et
quand les prostitu semble nécessaire on
met la morale de côté pendant la Grande
Guerre l'afflux des prostituées dans les
gare venant à la rencontre des
permissionnaires paraît justifié et sous
l'Occupation encore les responsable de
l'armée allemande pourtant obnubilé par
l'impératif sanitaire attendent encore
de la prostitution qu' canalise les
pulsion des
soldats l'histoire politique de la
vénalité
aussi ainsi entre le moral le médical le
social et la considération du mal
nécessaire comme le disait le philosophe
Augustin elle semble surtout soumise
pour reprendre les mots de l'historien
Alain Corbin je cite à la peur d'une
triple dégradation celle de la femme
prostituée celle de son partenaire celle
de l'argent et par ce billet celle de
l'ordre social
plusieurs courants de pensée vont
s'emparer par la suite du problème le
prohibitionnisme né au sein du féminisme
compassionnel et prédicateur anglais des
années
1870 considère les femmes prostituées
comme des victimes qu'il convient
d'arracher à leur mauvaise vie face à
lui il y a alors et il y a toujours ce
qu'on appelle entre guillemets les
abolitionnistes libéraux
le journaliste féministe du 19e siècle
Yv Guyot yvet roui ministre des Droits
de la femme qui envisage de dépénaliser
les prostituées en 1981
ou encore plus près de nous élisabeth
Badinter c'est dans cette lignée-ci que
pour ma part je tâche de m'inscrire une
lignée qui au nom de la dignité de la
femme et de valeurs universelles
condamne à la fois le réglementarisme
dégradant et le proxénétisme mais par
forcément la
prostitution aujourd'hui plus que jamais
le débat reste vif ce qu'on appelle
désormais les abolitionnistes entre
guillemets qu'on aurait qualifié avant
1914 de
prohibitionnistes vise à la disparition
pure et simple de la prostitution qui
est pour eux et pour elles avant tout
une intoléble atteinte au droits et à la
dignité des femmes d'autres juge cette
position illusoire tels les signataires
d'une tribune paru dans Le Nouvel
Observateur du 23 août 2012 où
ellisabeth Badinter l'historien du corps
George Vigarello la philosophe
ellisabeth de fonenet le sinaste Claude
lanzman et quelques autres se
déclaraient notamment contre une
pénalisation des clients parce qu'elle
ferait de la personne prostituée une
complice du délit et précariserait un
peu plus sa condition comme les délits
de racolage aujourd'hui l'idéologie
abolitionniste si l'on en croit les
signateur de ce texte du Nouvel
Observateur reposerait sur deux
postulats 1 la sexualité tarifée est une
atteinte à la dignité des femmes de les
prostituées sont toutes des victimes et
leurs clients tous des salot or la
prostitution mesdames messieurs est une
question bien plus complexes les
prostituées n'exercent pas toutes sous
la contrainte et la prostitution ne
concerne pas que les femmes les hommes
aussi se prostituent pardelà les
représentations littéraires ont songe à
Carco prou Gide Jeunet sax ou joind et
pardà les constants les constats
alarmistes des spécialistes de l'enfance
la prostitution masculine est et restait
un impensé des pouvoirs publics on
oublie les grands boulevards à la belle
époque la Place Blanche montmart
tropigal dans l'entre de guerre
Saint-Germain pendant les 30es
glorieuses la rue Saint-Anne dans les
années
1970 tous au lieu d'une prostitution
masculine occultée qui demeure un
problème de société mal connu pas même
convenablement chiffré quant aux femmes
qui font appel au service sexuel de
prostituer masculin le sujet n'est pas
moins tabou comme celui de
prostituer transgenre ou
transsexuel reconnaissant cette
complexité du phénomène la prostitution
peut être aussi mais elle ne l'est pas
seulement une atteinte à la dignité au
corps des femmes nulle position de
principe si généreuse soit-elle ne peut
en épuiser la réalité il n'est pas
jusqu'au statut juridique de la
prostitution en France qui ne soit
ambigu la prostitution chez nous n'est
pas illégale n'est-ce pas mais elle est
dans les fait seulement
tolérée ne sacrifions pas l'abrogation
du délit de racolage public instauré par
la loi de 2003 une abrogation que
j'appelle de mes vœux aujourd'hui et qui
est souhaitée par les féministes de
toute sensibilité ne sacrifions pas sur
l'hôtel de quelques idé logi que ce soit
cette abrogation cette abrogation ne
résoudra pas tous les problèmes j'en
conviens elle n'est que le début du
chemin mais pourquoi tarder à répondre à
une véritable urgence pourquoi ne pas
stopper sans délai le harcellement dont
tant de prostituées se disent victimes
les témoignages sont accablants de ces
femmes arrêtées plusieurs dizaines de
fois par an en 20ain certains policiers
font certes valoir voir que grâce à la à
la garde à vue des personnes prostituées
qu'autoriseent la répression de ce délit
il réussissent à démentanteler les
réseaux de proxenet l'instauration du
délit de racollage n'a pas rendu la
traque des proxenet plus efficace nous
avons les chiffres de la nouvelle chaîne
pénale qui nous qui témoigent de de ce
délit de ce
proxénétisme qui n'a pas été bien
encadré en revanche tous les rapports
disponibles celui de liigaz qui vous a
été remis madame madame nagette
valobelkassem en décembre dernier où
celui commandé par Médecins du Monde qui
vient de paraître tous soulignent les
méfait induits par la loi de 2003
dégradation de l'état de santé des
prostituées et des conditions de
pratique de la
prostitution augmentation de l'isolement
et de la clandestinité elle même propice
à la multiplication des violences
développement de surcroix de la
prostitution qu'on appelle indoor en
appartement dans les hôtels bar salon de
massage sur Internet facteur d'isolement
et de vulnérabilité supplémentaire et
qui coupe les personnes prostituées des
associations de prévention et d'aide
tout cela François Hollande le disait
lui-même dès le 19 mars 2 12 dans une
interview donnée au site
Seronet le déli à la racine de ces mots
inutiles a une histoire complexe que je
ne retracerai pas sa définition paraît à
NRE bien fragile et la frontière entre
racollage actif et racollage passif et
bien flou ainsi au regard de la
jurisprudence ne peut-être qualifié de
racollage actif le simple fait de
déambuler sur la voie publique dès que
la tenue vestimentaire peut être
considérée comme normale pour la période
et que la personne n'a fait que répondre
à des automobilistes arrêtés à sa
hauteur Cour de cassation
1996 numéro
726 même chose pour le racollage passif
la Cour de cassation ayant considéré le
25 mai 2005 que le délit n'est pas
constitué par le fait de stationner
légèrement vêtu la nuit au mois de
juillet
sur le trottoir et de répondre à un
client tant de souffran vaines donc sur
de Tell base pour punir
qui souvent les plus pauvres les plus
précaires qui ne font cela que pour
avoir de quoi manger et où dormir tel
est le constat mesdames les ministres
mes chers collègues qui justifie la
proposition de loi que je porte avec le
groupe
écologiste
parce que je suis femme et féministe
cette souffrance veaine de tant d'autres
femmes m unupportable parce que je suis
d'origine immigré je ne puis accepter
l'horreur du lot quotidien des personnes
prostituées étrangère parce que je suis
enseignante je ne puis tolérer que des
étudiants et des étudiantes se prostitue
pour souvenir à leurs besoins et parce
que je suis humaniste je ne puis croire
que la pénalisation soit la voie de la
rédemption sociale surtout lorsqu'elle
prend comme cible les plus vulnérables
des personnes prostituées pas les escort
girl par exemple qui ne sont nulement
touché par le délit de racollage comme
d'ailleurs leurs clients aisés ne
seraiit d'ailleurs pas touchés non plus
par la pénalisation du client
l'abrogation du délit de racolage public
créera un vide juridique gênant je ne le
crois pas faut-il revenir à la situation
d'avant 2003 et sanctionner le racolage
actif par une contravention de 5e classe
à supposé qu'on puisse clairement
préciser ce qu'il est faut-il à tout
prix qu'une personne prostituée soit
punie du seul fait qu'elle se prostiue
qu'elle paie pour qu'elle comprenne
qu'elle pêche comment soutenir d'un côté
que les prostituées sont des victimes et
de de l'autre les sancs
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues mettons sur pied une grande
loi de prévention d'insertion sociale et
professionnels de prise en charge de la
santé des personnes prostituées si nous
voulons sortir les personnes prostitué
étrangère de la prostitution alons alors
inspirons-nous des dispositions en
vigueur en Italie ou depuis
1998 si elle sort du réseau un permis de
séjour de 6 mois leurait accorderé
renouvelable pour 1 an si elle trouve un
emploi l'Italie est le seul pays
disposant d'une législation globale
permettant aux victimes qu'ell
collaborent ou non avec la police pour
dénoncer leur proxenet de recevoir le
soutien et l'aide nécessaire de même
permettons au transgendres de changer de
prénom même lorsqu'ils n'ont pas subi
une opération pour changer de sexe
opération de surcroix très coûteuse un
prénom sur les papiers d'identité qui
correspondent au genre adopté voilà qui
aiderait à leur insertion dans un emploi
ordinaire éviterait à certains et à
certaines d'être acculé à la
prostitution quant aux étudiants et aux
étudiantes aux maères de famille
précairire aux jeunes sans emploi ou à
l'emploi précaire prostitué occasionnel
donnons-leur les moyens de vivre et de
vivre mieux songeons enfin aux
associations de prévention et d'aide aux
prostituées qui ont vu malheureusement
ces dernières années leurs subventions
diminuer ce qui rend leur travail encore
plus difficile quant à la lutte contre
la traite des êtres humains et le
proxénétisme elle est assurément une
priorité absolu donnons-nous en les
moyens mais sans que la loi Vienne
encore ajouter à la souffrance et à la
stigmatisation des victimes de cette
traite rien de tout cela n'a à voir avec
le souci de la vertu ou de la morale il
est question là d'abord de justice et de
protection des plus faibles en abrogeant
sans contre-partie le délit instauré par
la loi de 2003 c'est bien œuvre de
justice et de protection que que nous
ferons le législateur est là pour cela
aussi pas seulement pour surveiller et
punir je reprends le titre d'un célèbre
livre de Michel foucot je vous
remercie
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à Virginie Cless rapporteur de la
commission des
lois
madame la présidente madame la garde
d'essau madame la ministre mes chers
collègues de quoi s'agit-il
aujourd'hui de débattre d'un texte qui
comprend 8
mots l'article
225-10-1 du code pénal est abrogé
8 mots mais quel poids dans ces mots et
qu'elle
attente pour on ne sait même pas combien
exactement 30000 sans doute
essentiellement des femmes
prostituées qui attendent notre décision
aujourd'hui des femmes dont tout le
monde quelques hommes dont tout le monde
a reconnu lors de toutes mes auditions
que c'était d'abord des
victimes et que cet article 225 t 10- 1
du Code
pénal les a conforté dans cette place de
victime les a vulnérabilisé dans cette
place de victime les a fragilisé dans
cette place de victime et les a
stigmatisé qui plus est vis-à-vis du
reste de la société comme si elle nétait
déjà pas assez les a éloigné des soins
les a éloigné du droit les a éloigné de
la possibilité via les associations de
s'en sortir
de trouver autre chose de faire autre
chose le droit français pourtant le
droit
français queles que soi les dispositions
qu'il prend veille toujours à protéger
les plus vulnérabl à alourdir les
sanctions lorsque les actes sont commis
contre les plus
vulnérables et
là en
2003 le droit
français a décidé que des victimes
vulnérables all être encore plus
victimes all être encore plus vulnérable
non pas pour le plaisir de le faire les
objectifs n'étaient bien évidemment pas
ceuxa les objectifs c'était les
contraindre à dénoncer leurs
tortionnaires les objectifs c'était
lutter contre les réseaux de
proxénétisme et ces objectifs là tout le
monde aussi les partage mais le moyen
pris pour y
arriver ce moyen est-ce qu' n'est pas
injuste ce moyen est-ce qu'on a pas le
devoir aujourd'hui de revenir dessus et
d'en construire un autre de construire
un vrai outil qui permette réellement
d'aider les prostitué un vrai outil qui
permette réellement de lutter contre les
réseaux de
proxénétisme alors pourquoi l'a-t-on pas
fait et pourquoi est-ce qu'on le fait
pas à l'occasion de ce texte de loi
parce que si c'était simple on l'aurait
tous fait depuis longtemps si c'était
facile et évident plein d'autres pays
l'auraient déjà fait on l'aurait
peut-être même fait les premiers en
France mais c'est pas simple c'est pas
évident et c'est complexe et pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas simple et pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas évident parce qu'on
touche là je pense à un cœur de
contradiction
française humaine parce qu'on touche à
ce qu'on a de plus intime peut-être qui
est dans notre la relation
sexuelle parce que l'on touche à la
pauvreté et à la
précarité parce que l'on touche à des
milieux de proxénétisme qui qui sont en
lien et on le sait tous avec les milieux
de la mafia avec les milieux de la
drogue avec les milieux du travail
clandestin avec l'argent sale donc c'est
pas simple donc c'est pas évident est-ce
que pour autant il fallait introduire
encore plus de confusion dans l'esprit
de nos citoyens vis-à-vis de ces femmes
vis-à-vis de ces hommes prostitués
est-ce que pour autant il était
nécessaire de créer cet
outil dont les policiers s'accordent
aujourd'hui à dire qu'il est pas très
très efficace finalement ils disent pas
qu'ils ont envie qu'on le retire ils
n'ont que celui-là ou quasiment que
celui-là ou c'est l'impression qu'ils
ont parce que tant qu'on l'a pas retiré
ils n'en cherche pas un autre ils ont
quand même celui-là ils le prennent mais
ils en ont d'autres les prostitués on
peut les entendre s le statut de témoin
assisté par exemple et là on a accès aux
mêmes informations que si on les entend
en garde à vue mais elles ne sont pas
hauteur d'un délit et quand on les
entend sous le statut de témoins
assister on peut fouiller leur sacs et
quand on les entend en garde à vue on
peut fouiller leur sac mais quand on les
end en garde à vue elles ne disent rien
elles ne disent rien quand on les entend
témoin assist non plus donc dans un cas
comme dans l'autre vous avez les mêmes
informations dans les sacs à main
c'est-à-dire les puces de téléphone qui
servent à remonter effectivement les
réseaux et le vrai travail de fourmir
des services de police auquel je rends
hommage aujourd'hui parce que vraiment
ils sont accrochés à cette idée de
démanteler les réseaux c'est là qu'il se
fait dans les sacs à main des prostitués
essentiellement c'est là qu'il se fait
parce que quand elles sont dans leur
bureau elles ne disent rien eux-mêmes
nous l'ont dit c'est exceptionnel le
nombre d'affaires qui sont démelé le
nombre de réseaux qui sont démelés grâce
aux informations données par les
prostitués quand vous imaginez que même
un interprète par exemple pour des
nigérianes refuse de rentrer dans le
bureau d'un inspecteur de police parce
qu'il y a la photo d'un proxénet et que
les croyances sont tellement fortes dans
cette population nigériane que ils sont
persuadés les interprètes que s'ils
aident la police c'est leur famille
reste au pays qui va subir les sorts du
proxenet qui est en photo simplement
photo dans le commissariat quand vous
imaginez ce genre de croyance enraciné
enraciné chez ces femmes qui sont là sur
nos trottoir qui parlent à pein français
mais comment peut-on imaginer qu'elles
vont pouvoir donner des informations
vraiment utiles et volontairement aux
policiers les informations il faut
qu'ils ayent les pêchés donc oui il faut
leur laisser les moyens d'aller les
pêcher mais ils peuvent continuer de le
faire même si le délit est abrogé parce
qu'ils peuvent continuer à les
rencontrer parce que ils peuvent
continuer à les entendre sous d'autres
statuts que celui de témoins et je crois
que c'est l'honneur du législateur que
de faire un droit clair transparent et
lisible quand une personne est victime
elle est victime on n pas on n'est pas
licite on n'est pas légitime à inventer
un délit pour contraindre la personne à
venir s'expliquer à venir porter plainte
à venir raconter ce que lui ont fait ses
tortionnaires un parallèle peut-être que
vous allez trouver oser mais est-ce
qu'il serait venu à l'idée d'un seul
d'entre nous de fabriquer un délit pour
que les femmes victimes de viol
conjugale viennent en garde à vue par
exemple à la gendarmerie pour porter
plainte contre leurs tortionnair non
elles sont victimes et uniquement
victime et même si c'est pas facile de
lutter contre les violences conjugales
il ne nous est jamais venu à l'idée de
fabriquer un délit pour mieux lutter
contre les violences conjugales alors
pourquoi cet amalgame pourquoi ces
confusions autour de la prostitution
parce que sans doute nous-mêmes chacun
d'entre nous chaque citoyen en France
n'est pas très très au clair vis-à-vis
de la prostitution qui sont les clients
peut-être des monsieurs tout le monde
sans doute des monsieurs tout le monde
pas seulement des pervers oui il y a des
monsieurs tout le monde dans les clients
très certainement et heureusement
d'ailleurs pour les prostitués s'il
avait que les pervers en plus leurs
clients je sais pas comment
survivra donc peut-être est-ce là notre
contradiction et peut-être est-ce pour
cela que nous avons maintenu ou laissé
se maintenir cette confusion
entre la prostituée victime la
prostituée auteur d'un délit le racolage
la prostitution qui n'est pas illégale
qui n'est pas illégal en France et nous
avons maintenu chez nos concitoyens
aussi cette confusion en faisant du
racollage un délit parce que tout ce que
j'entends moi quand je dis il faut
abroger ce délit tout ce que j'entends
c'est mais rendez-vous compte alors
comment va-t-on faire on trouve des
préservatifs entre les voiture l'acte
sexuel il est perpétré sur la voie
publique mais ça c'est un délit mais
c'est pas du racolage c'est l'exhibition
sexuelle sur la voie publicique c'est de
l'acte sexuel sur la voie publique et ça
c'est déjà un délit qu'on soit prostitué
ou pas que l'acte soit tarifé ou pas
donc l'outil il existe pour lutter
contre ces nuisancesl et quand on me dit
oui mais quand elles sont 10 sur le bord
de la route et qu'elles font du bruit du
tapage et cetera à 10h le soir ou à
minuit ou à je ne sais quelle heure mais
c'est déjà dans le code pénal ça
s'appelle le tapage nocturne et rien
nempêche les maires de prendre les
arrêtés municipaux en conséquence donc
il n'y avait pas besoin il n'y avait pas
besoin de transformer les prostituées en
délinquantes pour régler ses problèmes
de tranquillité publique tout est déjà
dans le code pénal donc créer des outils
de toutes pièces a parfois des
inconvénients et là l'inconvénient
majeur de cet outil créer de toutes
pièces c'est pas seulement les
associations qui font un travail
extraordinaire sur le terrain mais dont
on pourra toujours leur reprocher
qu'elles sont militantes c'est pas
seulement les associations c'est le
milieu médical qui crie au secours qui
dit attention problème de santé publique
attention paupérisation attention
vulnérabilisation attention les
prostituées se retrouvent dans des
conditions où leur vie est en danger
tous les jours parce que
individuellement à cause de cette
création du délit individuellement elles
sont sans arrêt bougé de place par les
proxénet et elles n'ont plus accès ni au
droits ni aux associations ni aux
médecins ni à personne et pourtant le
phénomène sur la voie publique est
toujours là et et pourtant personne ne
hurle contre Internet et pourtant
personne ne hurle contre les publicités
dans la presse quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs quelle qu'elle soit peut-être
pourrait-on se concentrer aussi
là peut-être pourrait-on mettre plus de
moyens
sur cette lutte là contre la
prostitution et contre les réseaux de
prxénétisme la prostitution liée au
réseau de prxénétisme trouvez-vous
normal qu'une chinoise qui a payé son
voyage via un emprunt persuadé qu'elle
va travailler dans une manufacture en
France pour rembourser son voyage se
retrouve au bout du compte tellement
exploité dans ses ateliers de travail
clandestin qu'effectivement elle va se
retrouver sur le trottoir à faire
prostituer sous l'emprise d'un réseau de
proxénétisme quel qu'il soit M même s'il
est très restreint non c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal parce qu'il faut aussi
lutter contre les réseaux de travail
clandestin donc le problème est immense
le chantier est gigantesque mais
commençons commençons par regarder les
choses en face on ne fait pas du droit
correctement tant qu'on ne regarde pas
les choses en face et le premier geste à
faire le premier pas à faire la première
main à tendre c'est de dire au prostitué
non le racolage n'est pas un délit la
prostitution n'est pas un délit
aujourd'hui en France le racollage n'en
est pas un mais ça ne suffit pas ça ne
suffit pas mais l'urgence est là
aujourd'hui et pendant qu'on règle cette
urgence je sais qu'il y a une mission à
l'Assemblée nationale je sais qu'il y a
une mission au Sénat je sais que les
ministères travaillent sur le sujet
comme quand le harcèlement avait été
brutalement aussi lui abrogé nous sommes
capables ensemble avec le même objectif
de nous mettre au travail de retrousser
les manches et rapidement mais pas dans
la bousculade de faire un grand texte un
vrai texte qui permettra de donner
vraiment des moyens au services de
sécurité de vrais moyens une fois de
plus pour remonter les réseaux pour
faire leur travail de fourmis
inlassablement mais avec de vrais outils
et pour démantel les réseaux de
proxénétisme et tout ce qui trafique
autour d'argent sale et dans
l'intervalle redonnons aux prostitués
l'accès aux soins l'accès aux
associations l'accès à des des
mécanismes d'insertion que sans doute
sans doute il
faut bonifier que sans doute il faut
consolider et puis donnonsleur les
moyens d'aller porter plainte si elles
le veulent en étant sécurisé en étant
tranquillisé en étant en sécurité et là
de réellement contribuer volontairement
au travail des forces de sécurité pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons et parce que
nous attendons avec une grande
impatience de travailler avec le
gouvernement Assemblée nationale et
Sénat sur ce grand texte contre le
proxénétisme et pour la prostitution non
pas pour promouvoir la prostitution mais
pour aider les prostitués
la commission m'a suivi et a donné un
avis favorable à ce texte je tiens à
préciser sans aucune voix contre les
quelques réticences qui se sont
exprimées étaaient lié au fait que le
calendrier fait que aujourd'hui ce texte
n'est pas là mais aujourd'hui l'urgence
elle est à rétablir le droit et à
rétablir les prostituéses dans leur rôle
de victime et non pas dans leur rôle
d'auteur
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à Jean-Pierre Sueur président de la
commission des lois vous avez la parole
chers
collègues madame la Présidente Mesdames
les ministres mes chers
collègues comment ne pas souscrire
au
plaidoyers
sincère qui viennent d'être fait par
Eser Benbassa et par Virginie
clè comment ne pas
partager ce qu'elles ont dit sur le
désarroi la souffrance des victimes sur
l'exploitation mais comment ne pas dire
aussi que nous
devons prendre ce texte pour ce qu'il
est un premier
pas mais que si nous faisons ensemble
mes chers collègues ce premier
pas cela n'a de sens que si les autres
pas
arrivent dans un temps
raisonnable je me souviens ici
même de ce que un certain nombre d'entre
nous ont pu dire lorsque fut instauré ce
délit de racolage
public une fois encore c'était une loi
qui avait pour effet de frapper
l'opinion combien y a-t-il eu de loi
dont le seul effet était de frapper
l'opinion il y a ce drame
il y a ce fait divers
ignoble il y a cette situation
insupportable et l'on arrive sur le
Peron de tels lieux important et sacrés
de la République et l'on dit voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
concitoyens il va y avoir une
loi comme si la loi pouvait magiquement
régler tous les
problèmes une loi sans
moyens ne sert à
rien et en l'espèce cette loi nous
l'avions
dit non seulement elle ne réglerait pas
le problème mais en plus elle aurait
cette conséquence qui a été si bien
décrite par ginie clè et par Esther
Benbassa cette conséquence de
transformer les victimes en
coupable et cela nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter et donc nous avions voter
contre cette disposition et par
conséquent il est logique de la brogir
aujourd'hui nous avons eu l'occasion
madame le garde des saau madame la garde
des saau de parler d'autres sujets je
pense aux peine planché je vais vous
dire mes chers collègues je visit très
mal dans une République qui a toujours
dans ses lois des peines planché je sais
que je ne suis pas le seul ici et que
les peines planché danst leur
principes sont pour nous pour beaucoup
une atteinte à l'indépendance et à la
capacité de jugement des
juge seulement nous en avons parlé
madame le garde desessau et je sais que
vous travaillez beaucoup sur ce sujet on
pourrait
abolir mais ce qui est important c'est
la nouvelle politique pénale que nous
allons mettre en œuvre à la suite de la
conférence de
consensus qui a été une innovation
considérable dans nos pratiques pour
préparer des textes de loi et a
contrasté avec ce que je disais tout à
l'heure qui était l'annonce éclairire de
texte éclair pour donner l'illusion que
l'on réglerait les
problèmes
alors moi je veux employer un mot qui
est le mot modestie et j'ajouterai le
mot
engagement si nous votons cela et nous
voterons cela moi je suis tout à fait
partisan de voter cette proposition de
loi il ne faut pas faire
croire que c'est plus que réparer une
erreur une mauvaise mesure mais ce n'est
pas encore et cela ne peut pas nous
dispenser cela doit au contraire nous
engager c'est pourquoi j'emploie le mot
engagement à préparer un texte
conséquent sur cette question de la
prostitution et je veux vous saluer à
votre tour madame Najat Vallot
Belkassem car j'ai pu
constater tout le soin que vous mettez à
écouter l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
quelque chose à dire sur ce sujet pour
préparer cette grande loi qui n'a pas
existé dans le passé dans l'histoire de
la République depuis longtemps et qui
est
attendu je sais aussi le travail que
vous faites au plan international
puisque le problème il est aussi
international et j'espère que dans les
mois qui viennent nous y arriverons en
tout cas si dans les mois qui viennent
nous n'y arrivions pas et bien ce serait
de notre faute collectivement je le dis
et il n'aurait pas suffi de voter ce
texte aujourd'hui je le dis pour mettre
les points sur les i de la même manière
je veux dire ici à cette tribune car
j'ai bien connu ces dispositions
que certaines mesures qui peuvent
frapper les esprits je pense aux arrêtés
municipaux sont bien souvent des mesures
qui n'ont pas d'effet
ou qui déplacent le
problème si vous dites que la
prostitution est interdite dans tel
endroit en vertu d'un arrêté municipal
elle va se déplacer dans l'endroit d'à
côté et le maire d'à côté va voir les
concitoyens venir dire mais enfin
pourquoi ne faites-vous pas comme votre
collègue et ensuite on ira au maire
suivant et puis on règlera rien on se
retrouvera dans les forêts dans les
faubourgs dans les dans les espaces
commerciaux dans les entrées de ville un
peu
partout
fausse
solution qui donne le change qui essaie
de donner le change mais qui ne règle
rien donc c'est
clair la création du racollage de du
délit racollage public est-ce qu'elle a
fait diminuer la prostitution
non est-ce que elle a permis aux
personnes prostituées qui le souhaite de
se réinsérer dans la vie professionnelle
et sociale la réponse est non est-ce
qu'elle a permis de lutter efficacement
contre les réseaux de proxénétisme la
réponse est
non donc demain il nous faut faire et
même aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui et je
pense que vous allez nous en parler
mesdames les ministres cette loi qui
comprendra au moins de volet sans doute
en faut-il bien d'autres mais au moins
de
voler
premièrement aider les pers personnes
prostituées qui veulent en sortir et qui
veulent se réinsérer dans une vie
professionnelle et social les aider à y
parvenir nous savons l'action des
associations je connais depuis très
longtemps ces mouvements nous sommes
nombreux à travailler en lien avec ces
mouvements et ces associations elles
font un travail qui est toujours plus
difficile en ce moment toujours plus
difficile ça veut dire qu'il faudra y
mettre les moyens parce que les paroles
ne suffiront pas pour parvenir à
proposer
une insertion professionnelle et sociale
aux personnes prostituées qui le
souhaiteront et deuxièmement il
faudra prendre des mesures on en parle
toujours mais il faudra le faire de
manière à lutter contre les réseaux de
proxénétisme ça veut dire concrètement
des personnels de police compétents et
spécialisés et des moyens donc des choix
et si on ne le fait pas et bien nous
aurons été riche en parole verbal donc
mes chers collègues je parle de cette
manière parce que je crois vraiment que
le respect d à ces personnes qui sont
des
victime
souvent le respect dû à ces personnes
consiste à voter cette première loi avec
la modestie nécessaire mais avec
l'engagement que nous prenons
publiquement ce soir au Sénat engagement
que nous nous devons de respecter je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président de
la Commission des lois la parole est à
Christian tobir garde des saau ministre
de la justice Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE madame
la
ministre madame la
Présidente merci
monsieur madame la ministre des Droits
des Femmes monsieur le président de la
commission des lois descend pas
davantage non
merci j'avais observer que le Sénat se
Famin isait se rajunissait mais il ne
raccourcit pas Madame la rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez eu raison monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
de rappeler le contenu extrêmement
roboratif d'ailleurs mais très
descriptif et très analytique des
interventions qui ont été présentées par
l'auteur de la proposition de loi Esther
Benbassa au nom de son groupe
parlementaire ainsi que par la
rapporteur Virginie class qui nous ont
brosser en fait le tableau de la réalité
de cette situation douloureuse difficile
et complexe de la prostitution et des
personnes qui on sont victimes lors de
la campagne présidentielle le président
de la République a pris très clairement
l'engagement d'abroger ce que nous avons
nous pris l'habitude d'appeler le
racolage public et qui en fait recouvre
d'une part l'ancienne incrimination de
racolage actif ainsi que le l'ancienne
contravention de 3e classe qui
s'appelait racolage passif et qui avait
été abrogé en 1994 10 ans donc après la
loi du 18 mars 2003 nous avons
l'occasion de proclamer très clairement
et vraiment à haute voie que les
personnes qui sont prostituées sont pour
la plupart d'entre elles pour la plupart
pour l'extrême grande majorité d'entre
elles des victimes des victimes de
violence des victimes de traites d'êtres
humains des victimes de domination des
victimes d'exploitation et que c'est la
réalité de ces personnes pourquoi
faut-il abroger cette incrimination dite
de de racolage passif mais d'abord parce
qu'elle frappe des personnes qui sont
fragiles vulnérables économiquement
socialement et juridiquement ensuite
parce que ce ce délit puisque cette
contravention est devenue un délit parce
que ce délit a éloigné ces personnes et
les a relégué dans des lieux où elles
sont encore plus exposés à la violence
dans des lieux isolés tels que des
forêts tels que des parkings isolés tels
que des terrain vague parce que ce délit
a aussi eu pour conséquence de les
mettre progressivement hors de portée
des interventions associatives et
médicales donc de les exposer à des
problèmes de santé individueles avec les
conséquences que l'on peut imaginer sur
le niveau de santé publique et
l'excellent rapport de Virg cl dans son
excellent rapport Viginie clè rappelle
le rapport de Ligas qui a indiqué
comment notamment par les analyses de
Médecins du Monde par les statistiques
établies par divers témoignages et par
une observation de la réalité comment
ces personnes prostituées échappent
effectivement aux interventions des
associations et des des structures
médicales il y a donc nécessité de
rappeler que ces personnes sont pour la
plupart des victimes on entend bien nous
entendons bien qu'il y a des personnes
qui se réclamament du choix de la
prostitution nous entendons bien ces
paroles de personnes qui affirment que
c'est un métier et qu'elles l'ont choisi
librement il nous faut voir c'est une
responsabilité politique d'être en
capacité de vérifier la réalité de ce
choix d'une part mais en tout état de
cause en tout état de cause la plupart
des personnes prostituées sont des
victimes des victimes de violence des
victimes de traite des victimes
d'exploitation et qu'elle relève souvent
de dispositifs à caractère social de
dispositifs liés à la formation
professionnelle de dispositifs
d'accompagnement et non pas bien entendu
d'un système de pénalisation et puis il
nous faut regarder du point de vue du
droit comment s'applique justement le la
caractérisation la définition de ce
délit et le prononcer d'une décision une
fois le délit constitué mais d'abord
parce que par qu'il faut le constituer
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut bien réunir les
éléments qui permettent de caractériser
une infraction qui démontre qu'il y a
une incitation à une relation sexuelle
tarifée cela suppose donc que pendant
l'élaboration de la procédure les
enquêteurs doivent être en mesure
d'apporter les preuves d'un comportement
d'une attitude d'une tenue vestimentaire
qui prouverait une incitation à une
relation sexuelle tarifée je ne connais
pas d'élément plus subjectif que ça pour
déterminer une
incrimination et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
rappelé madame la sénatrice ben Bassa la
Cour de cassation est déjà passée par là
et en 2005 notamment elle a indiqué que
devait être mise en cause une personne
qui avait une tenue vestimentaire
considérée comme légère qui se trouvait
sur le trottoir dans une zone réputée
pour être une zone de prostitution mais
il se trouve que la Cour de cassation a
estimé que c'est le client qui avait
pris l'initiative et que le délit de
racolage passif n'était donc pas
constitué il y a donc cette réelle
difficulté de définition de
l'incrimination ceci étant est-ce que
nous devons rester là regardant la
réalité la réalité d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être le l'exposé des motifs de la
loi de 2003 qui va nous expliquer
l'esprit dans lequel le législateur en
tout cas celui qui était l'auteur de ce
projet de loi l'esprit dans lequel le
législateur a élaboré ce texte de loi et
cet exposé des motifs dit bien
clairement que la mise en garde à vue la
prostitution n'étant pas une infraction
les deux sénatrices qui se sont
exprimées l'auteur et la rapporteur
l'ont rappelé la prostitution nétant pas
une infraction les le le but de ce
projet de loi était de faire mettre en
garde à vue des personnes prostituées
qui faudraitent interrogé et qui seraiit
susceptible de fournir des éléments
d'information à partir desquels des
enquêtes seraient ouverte contre les
proxinetes c'est-à-dire que ce délit de
racolage passif affiche explicitement
comme intention de vouloir lutter contre
le proximétisme soit soit simplement si
on peut considérer que l'objectif est
louable on a le droit d'avoir des doutes
sur les moyens parce que les moyens
consistent à faire des victimes des
auxiliaires de
police dans une certaine littérature on
appelle ça des
indicatrices et il se trouve que comme
par hasard il s'agit principalement de
femmes c'est-à-dire que ces victimes
sont utilisées comme des leurs comme des
appats pour toucher des réseaux de
proxinet vous rappeliez à juste titre
madame la rapporteur qu'il y a d'autres
moyens de pouvoir retirer des
renseignements qui sont essentiels
effectivement pour lutter contre le
proxéétisme le proxénétisme avoir accès
au renseignement autrement qu'en mettant
en garde à vue des
victimes parce que simplement on
l'entendait en les entendant comme
témoins et la loi permet de les entendre
comme témoins sous contrainte pendant 4
heures en les entendant comme témoins il
est possible d'obtenir ces ces
observations ces informations et
d'ailleurs la circulaire de juin 2003
qui accompagnait l'application de ce
texte de loi cette circulaire enjoignait
les procureurs à donner des instructions
aux enquêteurs pour que ces enquêteurs
interrogent systématique
ces personnes prostituées sur leur sur
leur proxinet sauf que les magistrats
nous disent très clairement que les
procèsverbaux sont
stéréotypés et que ces interrogations
n'aboutissent pas à des témoignages qui
permettent effectivement de remonter les
réseaux de proxénétisme il y a lieu
cependant de lutter contre ces réseaux
de proxineétisme et nous devons regarder
les résultats aussi en fait il y a une
augmentation des affaires élucidées
elles é était de 347 en 2000 elles sont
de elles étaient à monté à 565 en 2011
il y a incontestablement une
amélioration dans l'élucidation des
affaires impliquant des proxy netes
est-ce que cela signifie que les gardes
à vu de personnes prostituées ont
contribué de façon déterminante à la
l'amélioration de cette élucidation non
ça n'est pas établi d'une part et
d'autre part on peut même considérer que
la corrélation serait plutôt négatif
parce qu'on observe bien que le nombre
de garde à vue a baissé ces dernières
années c'est-à-dire de près de 5000 en
2004 il est tombé à un peu plus de 2000
en 2008 et à 1595 en 2011 il est évident
qu'il n'y a donc pas de relation directe
entre l'amélioration de l'élucidation
des affaires impliquant des proxy nets
et le maintien en garde à vue en tout
cas euh le le le le fait de pénaliser
des victimes nous avons donc là un vrai
problème de principe c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a incontestablement dans ce projet
dans ce texte de loi qui a une dizaine
d'années il y a un détournement de
finalité de la loi il y a un
détournement de procédure et puis en
plus il n'y a pas la preuve de
l'efficacité la question qui se pose à
nous aujourd'hui c'est de savoir comment
nous définissons nos objectifs nos
obligations et les exigences que nous
nous posons nous du point de vue du
droit et du point de vue des devoirs de
la puissance
publique je le rappelais la la
circulaire de
2003 demandait au procureur de faire en
sorte que ces personnes gardées à vue
puissent
apporter des informations sur les
proxyutes étant donné qu'on est passé
d'une contravention à un délit on est en
droit de penser que l'intention du
législateur était de d'aggraver les
peines
était de vouloir renforcer la répression
et donc d'une contravention qui donnait
lieu à des amendes passer à un délit qui
pouvait provoquer un prononcé de peine
d'emprisonnement qu'en est-il en réalité
en 2006 il y a eu 72 % d'Alternativ aux
poursuit en 2011 les juridictions sont
montées à 93 % d'alternatives aux
poursuites et 80 % de ces alternatives
aux poursuit constitu des rappels à la
loi qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors
certains avec leurs raccourcis habituels
vont dire que les juges sont
laxistes en réalité en réalité ce texte
de loi a créé des conditions pour
empêcher les enquêteurs d'être en mesure
d'apporter des preuves et les juges sont
face à des situations où les enquêteurs
ne peuvent pas apporter des preuves nous
avons vu comment constituer comment
caractériser l'incrimination le
comportement l'attitude l'appréciation
du comportement ement de l'attitude la
tenue vestimentaire bon on se souvient
des débats non vous êtes trop jeune ici
mais moi je m'en souviens des débat sur
les minijupes donc est-ce que l'attitude
vestimentaire est un élément objectif
qui permet de caractériser une
infraction donc il y a une réelle
difficulté pour les les enquêteurs
d'établir des preuves et les juges sont
devant ces situations en 2011 il y a eu
194 condamnations de
prononcé ces condamnations ont été pour
la plupart des amendes d'environ 300 €
et il y a eu six peines d'emprisonnement
prononcé dont allit savoir pourquoi cinq
dans la ville de Bézier j'ai interrogé
pour comprendre quelle était la
problématique on n' pas été en mesure de
me l'exposer très clairement mais bon
voilà sur 6 il y en a cinq dans la ville
de Bézier nous finirons par comprendre
sans doute les raisons pour lesquell il
y a 5/6e de condamnation
d'emprisonnement dans cette ville mais
voilà la réalité des faits donc nous
nous avons effectivement le devoir moral
et l'obligation d'aller au-delà et ce
que nous voulons faire c'est
effectivement lutter avec efficacité
contre les réseaux de traite et contre
le
proxinétisme nous voulons lutter avec
efficacité c'est-à-dire que nous voulons
nous en donner les
moyens aujourd'hui nous avons déjà dans
le droit un certain nombre de moyens il
faut savoir que le proxineétisme la
traite des êtres humains sont punis par
des sanctions lourde en correctionnel et
par des sanctions criminelles lorsqu'il
y a des circonstances aggravantes
qu'elles frappent des mineurs qu'elles
sont qu'elles sont exécutées effectué en
bande organisé ou qu'il y a pratique de
torture et les sanctions criminelles
sont effectivement lourdes puisqu'elles
peuvent attendre atteindre 20 ans elles
peuvent atteindre la réclusion
perpétuelle avec des amendes qui vendent
3ion 500000 € à 4 million d'euros nous
devons donc avoir les moyens de rendre
effectif effective l'application des
dispositions juridiques qui sont
inscrites dans notre droit nous voulons
lutter contre le proxénétisme les
réseaux de traite nous le faisons déjà
au niveau national en renforçant les
Girs vous savez ces juridictions
spécialisées qui lutent contre la
criminalité
organisée nous avons sensibilisé les
parquets à la nécessité de retenir la
qualification la plus élevée notamment
celle de traite des êtres
humains et nous travaillons à renforcer
le cadre normatif de la coopération
internationale parce que c'est une
criminalité organisée
transnationale et nous développons donc
ces outils juridiques et judiciaires qui
nous permettent d'améliorer ce cadre
normatif c'est-à-dire l'entraite pénale
internationale le mandat d'arrêt
européen les équipes commune d'enquête
mais également l'orientation des
procédures sous l'angle financier et
l'angle patrimonial ainsi que le le
repérage systématique des circuits de
blanchiment d'argent nous renforcons
nous renforçons son cela mais en plus il
nous faut développer une dynamique qui
inclut les victimes d'une autre façon et
inclure les victimes d'une autre façon
c'est d'abord leur reconnaître le le
statut de victime et faire en sorte que
y compris les dispositions qui sont déjà
inscrites dans notre droit soi
effectives c'est-à-dire assurer une
protection des victimes parce que
jusque-l on a vu que il fallait demander
à ses victimes en garde à vue de donner
le nom de leur proxinet c'est-à-dire en
fait de les exposer elle-même à des
représailles et donc à plus de violence
sans contrepartie mais il faut que les
victimes soit protégé et la loi déjà
notre droit contient déjà des
dispositions qui permettent de protéger
ses victimes notamment nous savons
qu'avec les réseaux de traite il y a des
victimes qui sont de nationalité
étrangère et l'article 3161 du code
cedda sur l'entrée et le séjour des
étrangers et des demandeurs d'asile
permet permet de protéger ses victimes
il faut le mettre en œuvre cet article
parce que vous rappeliez madame la
sénatrice Benbassa que il y a des
dispositions équivalentes en Italie nous
les avons dans notre droit simplement il
faut reconnaître qu'effectivement ces
dispositions ne sont guerre appliqué il
nous faut aussi travailler c'est ce que
nous faisons sur le statut du repenti
qui a été créé par la loi du 9 mars 2004
et qui n'est pas mise en œuvre d'abord
parce que le les décrets nécessaires
n'ont pas été pris qu'est-ce que le
statut du repenti alors évidemment je
suppose que chacune chacun d'entre vous
comme moi-même a un h cœur lorsque on
évoque le statut du repenti la réalité
c'est que c'est une méthode
d'investigation
et de procédure qui permet en fait à une
personne qui a été auteur déjà d'acte
délictueux ou criminel ou qui en a été
complice ou qui connaît des complices et
qui sé de s'exprimer pour éviter la
commission de d'autres actes délictueuse
ou criminelle il s'agit de faire en
sorte que le renseignement parvienne
de telle façon que l'on puisse éviter de
nouveaux actes délictueux et criminels
c'est un statut qui est à l'étude qui
est extrêmement compliqué à élaborer et
qui a un cout de sorte que il n'est pas
encore finalisé mais depuis plusieurs
mois nous travaillons au ministère de la
Justice avec le ministère de l'Intérieur
nous allons aboutir notamment
normalement au mois d'avril nous aurons
mis en place le statut des repentis de
sorte que nous pourrons mobiliser deux
outils qui sont à notre disposition i le
premier c'est la réduction et
l'exemption de peine qui est déjà prévu
par la loi expressément justement pour
la criminalité organisé justement contre
la traite et justement contre le
proxénétisme donc ce sont des outils
juridiques et judicières qui doivent
être mis en œuvre et puis il y a un
autre outil c'est celui justement de des
mesures de protection et de réinsertion
et le statut des repentis y contribuera
simplement nous avons besoin d'un décret
en Conseil d'État qui n'a pas été pris
depuis la loi de 2004 et l'aboutissement
de nos travaux avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur nous permettra de soumettre
prochainement un projet de décret voilà
à partir de quelle disposition nous
allons renforcer la lutte contre le
proxinétisme et contre la trite qui doit
être une l une lutte livrée sans merci
et nous avons par ailleurs quelques
autres chantiers vous savez qu'au mois
d'avril nous allons présenter au
Parlement diverses un projet de loi euh
portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation de textes européens et
internationaux et notamment
d'une règlement d'une directive
européenne de
2011 qui vise la lutte contre la traite
et le
proxénétisme de même que un une
directive européenne crée des
rapporteurs nationaux dans la lutte
contre la traite et le prox proximétisme
et nous allons désigner très
prochainement le rapporteur national
français et nous sommes en train de
travailler à un projet de décret pour
une mission interministérielle de
coordination et de prévention de la
lutte contre la traite des êtres humains
et contre le proxinétisme ces chantiers
sont en cours vous avez rappelé
vous-même tout à l'heure mesdames les
sénatrices et monsieur le président de
la commission des lois les missions qui
existent qui sont déjà en œuvre et au
travail à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat il y a donc nécessité
effectivement d'abroger ce délit il il a
sans doute à considérer comment pour une
plus grande efficacité pour une plus
grande efficacité cette abrogation
s'inscrira s'inscrira dans un projet
plus global qui sera soumis au Parlement
par la ministre des Droits des femmes
dans quelques mois sous le bénéfice de
toutes ces appréciations de ce partage
d'analyse de ces conviction commune que
nous ne devons
pas nous complaire dans le St statut de
délinquant attribué à des personnes qui
objectivement sont des victimes le
gouvernement aimet exprime
un avis de sagesse que nous allons
nuancer en disant que c'est une sagesse
favorable pour ce texte en insistant sur
la nécessité effectivement d'une action
plus globale à laquelle la ministre des
des droits des femmes travaille
d'arrachet d'arrachepied nous avons déjà
un arsenal judiciaire nous devons dev
nous donner les moyens par des
politiques publiques par une rigueur
sans faille les moyens de rendre
applicable cette Arsenal judiciaire de
façon à bien faire savoir à ceux qui
pratiquent cette traite des êtres
humains à ceux qui pratiquent le
proxénétisme à ceux qui
s'enrichissent sur le travail
l'exploitation et la domination de
personnes vulnérables que la puissance
publique sera à leur égard sans pitié
merci
merci madame la garde des
saau la parole est à Madame nagette
vallau Belkassem ministre des Droits des
Femmes et porte-parole du gouvernement
vous avez la parole madame la
ministre madame la
présidente madame la garde d'essau
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
chacun des chantiers investis par le
ministère qui est le mien le ministère
des Droits des femmes qu'il concerne ces
chantiers et l'école le monde du travail
les violences qu'il touche à l'espace
public ou encore à l'intimité familiale
chacun de ces chantiers nous impose à
chaque fois de regarder une réalité qui
n'est pas agréable à voir mais qui est
très trop présente dans notre société
les inégalités entre les sexes et les
violences que dans les cas extrêmes ces
inégalités peuvent engendrer qui sont
partout souvenons-nous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de l'échange que
nous avons eu ici même c'était il y a 10
mois au sujet du harcèlement sexuel un
drame social trop négligé dans notre
parole collective et que nous avons
finalement réussi à rétablir dans sa
cruelle vérité dans sa triste réalité à
savoir un délit destructeur pour les
victimes au commencement des violences
faites aux femmes il y a souvent
l'insulte avec sa charge haineuse
pardon de prononcer ce mot dans
cette enceinte il est choquant mais au
fond il est moins choquant que les
réalités qu'il recouvre choquant parce
que ce mot est devenu le mot valise dans
lequel se déverse l'oppression ordinaire
des femmes une insulte que les
enfants s'envoient à la figure dans les
cours d'école sans même en comprendre le
sens une simple insulte qui peut-être
lancée comme par réflexe au détour d'une
phrase au coin d'une rue à la fenêtre
d'une voiture une insulte que les hommes
violents utilisent toujours comme une
arme pour mieux humilier leur victime
traiter une femme de vous
m'excuserez encore d'abuser de ce terme
mais je crois qu'il est des
circonstances où il convient de dire et
de nommer les choses qu'on veut
combattre c'est nier son identité c'est
la réduire à un objet destiné à la
satisfaction d'autruie c'est projeté à
sa figure des millénaires d'oppression
et
d'asservissement partout on prononce ce
mot ouvertement donc mais honé en
réalité ce qu'il
désigne ce paradoxe nous renvoie à une
constante de la condition féminine
honter les violences que les femmes
subissent et ce faisant on se prive des
moyens de les en protéger la
prostitution n'est rien d'autre que
l'exacerbation au quotidien de ces
violences mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans tous les combats pour les
droits des femmes nous devons sans cesse
inlassablement lutter contre cette
prétendue fatalité qui imprime les
comportements de nos concitoyens aucune
loi de la nature ne les impose ces
comportements l'antériorité et la
longévité des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes n'en font pas une
fatalité le meilleur allié de ces
inégalités c'est la façon dont on les
minimise dont on les enolive autrefois
on parlait à propos de prostitution de
fill de noce de fill de joie de fille
publique ou encore dangoleuse comme pour
mieux cacher une réalité qui avait
envahi tout le corps social et qui était
autrement plus violente que cette forme
de gaieté pudique vous l'avez rappelé
madame Benbassa dans votre introduction
après avoir été poursuivi exécuté même
pendant la Terreur les prostituées
furent de nouveau toléré au 19e siècle
où les maisons closes étaient
surveillées par la police et contrôlées
par des dispensaires dans des conditions
militaire déplorable la Première Guerre
mondiale a engendré son lot de bordel
des bordels militaires de campagne qui
fournissaient en quelque sorte des
femmes des corps pour satisfaire les
besoins d'hommes détruits par les
combats et par les horreurs quotidiennes
cet argument d'ailleurs du besoin
irrépressible des hommes n'a pas tout à
fait disparu il m'arrive encore de
l'entendre souvent pour justifier une
réalité qu'il faudrait tolérer au nom
d'une histoire que l'on croit écrite
d'avant avance je ne crois pas aux
histoires écrites d'avance s'il en
fallait une preuve souvenons-nous
qu'après la Seconde Guerre mondiale nous
avons su tourner la page de cette
prostitution de masse la France a alors
fait valoir une position abolitionniste
dans le prolongement de la loi Marte
Richard nous avons mis fin au fatalisme
non pas parce que la prostitution
portait atteinte aux bonnes murs comme
c'est dit parfois mais parce qu'elle
portait atteinte au droit des
prostituées notre droit n'est pas resté
par la suite la sanction des clients des
mineurs des prostitué mineurs est
désormais prononcé quel que soit le pays
dans lequel l'acte est commis notre
droit c'est lentement construit et il
reste à construire aujourd'hui quand on
regarde la situation de notre pays quels
que soi les incertitudes que nous ayons
sur les chiffres exacts de la
prostitution on constate qu'elle a
reculé et qu'elle a profondément changé
de visage savez-vous que si on confronte
nos chiffres à ceux du ministère de la
Famille allemand il y a entre 10 et 20
fois moins de prostituées en France
qu'en Allemagne nous sommes entre 20 à
40000 prostitués en France contre 400000
outrerin cette comparaison mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs doit nous
inviter quand même à penser que les
choix différents que font les
législateurs se traduisent sur le
terrain par des réalités
différent comprenez-moi bien la question
n'est pas de savoir quelle doctrine
gagne mais quelle réponse la plus
efficace possible on peut apporter aux
réalités
d'aujourd'hui cette réalité nous la
connaissons il n'y a pas une
prostitution mais de multiples
phénomènes qu'il faut prendre en compte
dans leur diversité car il serait
illusoire de vouloir donner une réponse
unique à des réalités sociales cliniques
juridiques si différentes il y a la
prostitution visible celle qui s'exerce
dans la rue il y a la prostitution sur
Internet qui se développe à toute allure
et qui teste nos capacités
d'investigation il y a la prostitution
étudiante occasionnelle dont l'ampleur
est aujourd'hui très mal connu une étude
est menée par mes services en langue de
croussillon je vous en ferai part dès
qu'elle sera
achevé et puis nous devons aussi nous
poser des questions sur des réalités
encore plus dures sur les réalités
spectaculaires par exemple d'une
prostitution qui commence au collège
lorsque des jeunes à l'âge où on
découvre la sexualité
participe à la négociation d'une
relation sexuelle tarifée c'est que
quelque chose a échoué dans
l'apprentissage du respect d'autruie à
l'école et c'est tout le sens du travail
que nous sommes en train de mener avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
pour le respect entre les filles et les
garçons à l'école mais ce qui fait masse
plus encore que toutes cell que je viens
d'évoquer dans notre pays ce qui fait
masse c'est la prostitution systématisée
c'est le trafic d'êtres humains dont des
organisations criminelle transnationale
fournissent et refournissent nos
trottoir occupant ainsi la place laissée
vacantees par les milieux traditionnels
très structurés ces mafias vont recruter
leurs victimes dans des pays dans leurs
pays d'origine les conduisent ici où
elles n'ont pour la plupart aucune
attache familiale elles ne parlent pas
français elles vivent le plus souvent
sans aucun titre de séjour dans la peur
elles doivent rembourser au réseaux
criminel le coût très élevé de leur
immigration jusqu'à 50000 €. elles sont
contraintes à se prostituer à des tarifs
extrêmement faibles et dans des
conditions sanitaires
déplorables je pense en vous disant cela
aux jeunes nigérianes aux jeunes femmes
issu de la communauté pzigane aux jeunes
chinoises qui rapatrient ensuite
l'ensemble des profits générés dans
leurs pays respectifs par mandat par
porteur ou via un système de banquier
officieux qui œuvre au sein de leur
communauté permettez-moi mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'avoir une
pensée aujourd'hui pour ces victimes qui
souffrent et qui se trouvve ainsi
emprisonnés dans des vies de misère dans
des vies de violence les réseaux
mesdames et messieurs nous regardent ils
ils suivent ce que nous sommes en train
de faire ils guettent les failles de
notre législation ils ne comprennent
qu'un message les réseaux c'est celui de
la fermeté c'est pour cela que
aujourd'hui nous devons tenir un
discours clair et veiller à mettre en
cohérence nos paroles et nos actes alors
à cette tribune je veux le dire avec la
plus grande clarté possible la France
n'est pas un pays d'accueil de la
prostitution n portes nos portes doivent
rester fermées au vent mauvais de la
traite et des trafics je
suis je suis extrêmement sensible à cet
égard aux arguments qui ont été
développés par par la rapporteur
Virginie Cless dont je tiens à saluer le
travail et le rapport particulièrement
bien informé les pouvoirs publics ont en
réalité pendant longtemps été piégés
dans leurs hésitations leurs
contradictions mais nous n'avons
aujourd'hui pas d'hésitation nous sommes
portés par une conviction la conviction
que la prostitution est une violence et
cela doit nous encourager à lutter
contre l'entrée en prostitution cela
doit nous encourager à protéger les
personnes prostitué à développer leur
accompagnement sanitaire et social cela
doit nous encourager à faciliter la
sortie de la prostitution par un travail
d'insertion qui est à renouveler sans
cesse bien sûr qui est dur qui est long
mais qui est
indispensable la France est
abolitionniste cette position ne rend ni
aveugle ni angélique la prostitution
existe bel et bien dans notre pays
nombreux d'entre vous le savent qui sont
Mair et qui de devait au quotidien
composer entre la sécurité des personnes
prostituées et les attentes légitimes
des des riverins qui sont aussi à
prendre en
considération qu'est-ce qu'une politique
abolitionniste pour moi elle repose sur
deux piliers la fermeté pénale et
l'insertion sociale cela a des
conséquences très concrètes que nous
devons aborder sans posture moralisante
et avec pragmatisme c'est ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui autour de cette
proposition de loi la création en 2003
du délit de racolage passif a conduit
clairement là où il a donné lieu à des
poursuites à des situations inacceptable
avec ce délit on marche sur la tête en
punissant les victimes ce sont bien les
victimeses qui en ont subi les effets de
fait les violences se multipliant
lorsque pour échapper à la sanction les
personnes prostituées ont fini par
disparaître dans les zones les plus
reculées on ne réglera aucun problème en
passant les menottes aux personnes
prostituées et on provoque au contraire
de nombreux drames en les éloignant des
structures
d'accompagnement je sais le nombre de
stratégies d'évitement si préjudiciable
à la santé publique que ce délit
dracolage passif a créé toutes les
associations le savent j'étais encore il
y a quelques jours avec Médecin du Monde
vous évoqueiez le rapport de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales qui oui n'a fait que confirmer
ce que nous savions déjà nos craintes et
la conclusion simple que nous
réaffirmons ici c'est que nous devons
cesser de faire payer au plus vulnérabl
le prix de leur souffrance nous nous
sommes engagés à abroger ce délit de
racolage passif cet engagement sera
évidemment
tenu cependant abroger le délit de
racollage passif ne signifie aucunement
laisser le champ libre au réseau il ne
signifie aucunement admettre une
quelconque forme d'impunité à l'égard
des proxénet c'est tout le contraire et
c'est précisément ce qui nous a conduit
à vouloir resituer ce débat dans un
cadre plus large que beaucoup d'entre
vous ont évoqué un travail est en effet
en cours en ce moment même à l'Assemblée
nationale autour de Catherine Coutel ma
d'Olivier guigeau froid et d'autres ici
au Sénat autour de Jean-Pierre Godfroy
et Chantal jouanau je sais que les
sénatrices et les sénateurs de la
délégation des droits des femmes sont
aussi très impliqués sur le sujet
Brigitte Gontier main Christian de
moness merci pour votre engagement je
crois que ce travail qui va être riche
de ces differs de ces diverses
initiatives va permettre d'approfondir
les questions et d'avoir ce débat serein
dont nous avons cruellement manqué ces
dernières années il conduira sans doute
à l'élaboration de proposition de loi
pour répondre à votre requête monsieur
le sénateur sueur et c'est dans ce cadre
que le gouvernement définira alors
définitivement ses positions donc la
proposition de loi dont nous discutons
cet après-midi ne peut peut-être que le
prélude de ce travail plus général le
cœur de notre politique pénale en
matière de prostitution doit reposer sur
la sanction du proxénétisme cela a bien
été dit par ma collègue la garde des
saau sachez qu'avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous donnons les consignes
les plus claires aux forces de l'ordre
sur ce sujet et je voudrais tout de même
rendre hommage ici au travail de
l'Office central pour la répression de
la traite des êtres humains qui a
intensifié son action contre les réseaux
qui a mobilisé davantage de groupes
d'interventions régionaux sur ce sujet
et c'est ainsi qu'en 2012 51 réseaux ont
pu être démantelés soit 30 % de plus
qu'il y a 2 ans 572 proxénet arrêtés ce
sont de bons résultats que nous voulons
encore amplifier en renforçant notamment
la coopération internationale sujet
essentiel s'il en est notamment dans les
zones transfrontalière je pense par
exemple à cette zone de tension
particulière que vous connaissez tous à
proximité de la jquera au lieu du
proxénétisme et de la traite au fin
d'exploitation sexuelle ce qu'on y voit
c'est que les différences entre les
législations et la faiblesse des
réponses de l'Union européenne en la
matière font toujours des victimes je
pense au-delà des zones transfrontalière
je pense aux réalités internationales
vous savez on parle un peu benoitement
de tourisme sexuel lorsqu'un client
français se rend dans des pays où il
trouve des personnes prostituées on
parlera plus clairement généralement de
réseau de traite des êtres humains
lorsque réciproquement au rythme
d'épisodes géopolitique plus ou moins
tragique des centaines ou des milliers
de victimes étrangères chinoises
nigérianes rejoignent la France dans des
conditions inhumaine pour y être
exploité et bien dans toutes ces
situations je crois que nos marges de
progrès sont encore assez considérables
j'ai rencontré ce matin la nouvelle
présidente d'Interpol avec laquelle nous
allons travailler sur le sujet ma
collègue Christian tobira vous l'a dit
ici nous menons une action résolue
contre la traite nous avons même ouvert
ce chantier dès notre arrivé dans la
circulaire du ministre de l'Intérieur
sur la naturalisation nous avons rappelé
les droits au séjour dont disposent les
victim de traite un sujet sur lequel je
crois revient un des amendements
proposés avec le projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions d'adaptation dans
le domaine de la justice très
prochainement vous vous verrez proposé
par la garde des saau d'élargir les
conditions de qualification de
l'infraction de traite des êtres humains
nous avons créé en janvier dernier avec
la contribution de mes collègues de la
justice de l'Intérieur et des affaires
sociales laampr dont nous avions parlé
ici au moment du débat sur le
harcellement sexuel souvenez-vous ce
fameux observatoire national des
violences faites aux femmes qui est donc
qui a vu le jour qui s'appelle la
mission interministérielle pour la
protection des femmes et pour la
coordination de la lutte contre la
traite cette instance existe elle s'est
mise au travail elle est chargée
d'animer le travail gouvernemental sur
ce sujet et c'est ainsi que nous
présenterons un plan global contre la
traite des êtres humains à l'automne
prochain et ce plan sera conçu pour
renforcer l'action répressive la
coopération internationale mais aussi
élément essentiel vous le savez pour
former les professionnels de police à
cette infraction qui apporte des droit
aux victimes et qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus fréquemment utilisé
qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
en conclusion mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs un dernier mot pour vous dire
que la fermeté donc est essentielle mais
le message pénal n'a de sens que s'il
est accompagné d'une pédagogie et à cet
égard je crois qu'il faut s'interroger
sur la péédagogie faite à l'égard du
client notamment du client de la traite
nous regardons vous le savez toutes les
expériences international celle de la
Suède bien sûr mais aussi du Royaume-Uni
du
Danemark gardz à l'esprit lorsqu'on
évoque ces sujets que en France d'ors et
déjà les clients de prostituées mineur
ou de femmes vulnérables sont sous le
coup de la loi pénale gardez à l'esprit
que comme vous l'avez rappelé certaines
municipalités livré à elle-même agissent
par des arrêtés municipaux en dehors de
tout cadre
juridique je sais que certains
amendements sont présentés aujourd'hui
dans cette discussion sur ce sujet je
les trouve très intéressants mais ils
sont sans doute prématuré et nous devons
avoir une réflexion apaisée et muûrie
avant de nous prononcer enfin la
politique
pénale ne couvre qu'une partie de notre
sujet nous devons aussi aborder les
questions d'éducation de santé
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
nous devons penser à un large plan
d'inclusion sociale et professionnel des
personnes prostituées qui puissent leur
donner accès à des mesures de prévention
efficace à des programmes d'insertion
professionnelle adapté l'IGAS dont je
parlais tout à l'heure a ainsi mis en
évidence un accroissement
extraordinairement rapide des risques
sanitaires cela appelle de notre part
des réponses tout aussi rapides liigas
rappeler ainsi que le taux de mortalité
est deux fois plus élevé chez les femmes
se prostituant dans la rue par rapport à
des femmes d'âge comparable ce chiffre
doit nous ébranler c'est une réalité
insoutenable rien à cet égard ne
remplace le travail des acteurs de
terrain vous l'avez dit madame la
sénatrice Cless notamment ces
associations qui vont vers les personnes
prostituées et qui mettent en œuvre des
actions de prévention qui s'intègrent à
leur
environnement à cet égard je veux vous
dire que opposer abolition et protection
c'est un mauvais procès dont je ne veux
plus la réalité c'est que d'ors et déjà
le ministère qui est le mien a renforcé
les moyens d'évolu à l'accompagnement
des personnes prostituées d'ors et déjà
en ces temps budgétaire contraint j'ai
voulu faire en sorte que les
associations quel que soit d'ailleurs
vous évoquiez parfois leur militantisme
quel que soit leur position quel que
soit leur projet de société dès lors
qu'ell viennent en aide et en appui à
ces personnes prostituées puissent être
accompagné et je fais mienne les
recommandations de l'IGAS sur la
nécessité de consolider le rôle de ces
associations et de simplifier leur
financement j'ai demandé à mes services
de me faire rapidement des propositions
sur la manière d'assurer une meilleure
cohérence des financements entre le
niveau national les collectivités
locales en
particulier toujours pour suivre les
recommandations de ce rapport IGAS qui
était fort instructif sachez que un
travail spécifique est en cours de
construction avec les conseils généraux
pour que les dispositifs de protection
qui existent dans le cadre de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance puisse être
également pleinement mobilisé pour
protéger les prostituées mineur car il y
en a et enfin il est prioritaire
d'accroître l'effort de prévention
notamment en le rendant plus effectif
sur Internet là aussi la réflexion est
engagée je serais très heureuse de vous
y associer mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sur tous ces sujets je crois
que le pire danger qui gâte les
prostituées c'est la division partisane
parce que cette division partisane
enferme les enjeux dans des polémiques
vaines et enferment les victimes dans le
silence en prenant parfois des postures
clivantes moralisantes nous avons
pendant trop longtemps esquivé repoussé
abandonner le travail de fond
indispensable sur la politique que nous
voulons ça n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
grâce à la somme de travail
parlementaire qui a été accompli à la
fin de l'année 2011 à laquelle je tiens
vraiment à rendre hommage je parle du
travail réalisé par guoffroid et Daniel
bousqu à l'Assemblée nationale qui a
abouti à la résolution que vous savez
adoptée à l'unanimité
en conclusion et cette fois-ci c'est une
véritable
conclusion vous savez parmi les phrases
les plus définitives et les plus
inutiles prononcé trop souvent dans les
débats sur la prostitution il en est une
qui conduit à une profonde erreur
d'analyse cette phrase c'est celle selon
laquelle la prostitution serait le plus
vieux métier du
monde mais la réalité c'est qu'il n'y a
rien rien d'ancien dans les formes de la
prostitution que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que les
prostitutions que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui n'ont rien en commun avec
celle d'hier qu'elles se renouvellent et
qu'elles font sans cesse de nouvelles
victimes la plus vieille histoire du
monde au fond ça n'est pas celle d'un
métier la plus vieille histoire du monde
c'est celle que décrivait déjà Victor
Hugo dans Les Misérables en 1862 que je
ne peux que vous rappeler aujourd'hui
encore on dit que l'esclavage a disparu
de la civilisation européenne c'est une
erreur il existe toujours mais il ne
pèse plus que sur les femmes et il
s'appelle prostitution mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous avons
réussi à construire un consensus
transpartisan extrêmement précieux
autour de quelques valeurs et principes
d'action simple sachez que je mesure
totalement la force de ce consensus
comptez sur notre gouvernement pour le
faire fructifier je vous
remercie merci Madame madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la par la parole est à Laurence Cohen du
groupe CRC pour 7
minutes madame la Présidente Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues cela a
été souligné par les différents
interlocuteurs avant moi et par
notamment Esther Benbassa auteur de
cette PPL ainsi que Virginie cl
rapporteur 10 ans après la loi sur la
sécurité intérieure force de constater
son échec lors de nos débats en 2002 il
n'est pas inutile de redire ici que le
groupe CRC avait dénoncé et rejeté la
stigmatisation des prostituées donc par
cette instauration du délit de racollage
ainsi et nous l'avons dit encore
aujourd'hui ce sont les victimes qui
étaient et sont toujours criminalisés et
non les réseaux de prostitution si
l'objectif affiché était atteindre
indirectement les proxénet l'objectif
réel dévoilé par Monsieur Sarkozi à
l'époque ministre de l'intérieur était
de faire cesser la prostitution qui
envahit nos villes je le cite et nos
boulevards dans un souci de tranquillité
publique pour les Riverin et dans une
volonté de reconduire à la frontière des
prostituées étrangères peu importe le
devenir de ces personnes dès lors
qu'elle n'apparaissent plus sur les
trottoirs quelle hypocrisie j'ai envie
de reprendre la célèbre phrase du
tartuve de Molière cacher ce sein que je
ne saurais voir cette nouvelle mesure
purement sécuritaire va donc à
l'encontre de l'engagement de la France
pays abolitionniste qui s'est déclaré
comme tel grâce notamment à l'action de
nombreuses associations et je pense au
ni et à la Fondation céeste nous
redisons donc avec force qu'en
pénalisant et en stigmatisant les
personnes prostituées le gouvernement de
l'époque se trompait de cible 10 ans
après l'adoption de cette loi que
constatons-nous menacer les personnes
prostituées sont contraintes comme ça a
été dit de quitter les principaux
boulevards les centres-villes mais elles
sont toujours aussi nombreuses elles se
trouent relégué dans des endroits isolés
à la périphérie des grandes
améliorations et cet isolement cette
clandestinité leur font courir de très
grave danger pouvant aller jusqu'à des
violences mortelles et les privent
notamment de l'accès aux moyens de
prévention des maladies sexuellement
transmissible et de tout accompagnement
de soutien quelques chiffres pour
illustrer mon propos issu du rapport qui
vient d'être rendu public suite à la
commission d'enquête réalisée par la LDH
le Syndicat de la magistrature et le
Syndicat des Avocats sur la situation
des prostituées chinoises à Paris 63 %
des femmes ont été confrontées à des
retraites préservatif non consentis 55 %
ont été victimes de violence physique 38
% de viol 23 % de séquestration 17 % ont
fait l'objet de menace de mort on voit
là que l'idée du choix VO en éclat avec
la loi votée il y a 10 ans les personnes
prostituées se trouvent toujours au cœur
de multiples violences et privé de fait
de leur statut de victime pourtant il
faut le dire et le redire ici avec force
on estime que 85 à 90 % voire 95 %
d'entre elles sont sous le jou de
proxénet ou de réseau de proxinetisme
c'est donc sur ces derniers et non sur
les prostituées qu'il faut concentrer
les efforts de répression et j'apprécie
particulièrement les interventions de
madame la garde des saau sur ce sujet la
culture du chif que des syndicats de la
police nationale dénoncent eux-même en
parlant de cours au quotas de PV de
garde à vue empêche les forces de
l'ordre de faire autre chose que la
répression il est donc tempants de
sortir de cette approche répressive
dirigé seulement contre les victimes que
sont les prostituées pour rechercher et
sanctionner en priorité les responsable
de réseau qui organise la traite des
êtres humains la suppression du délit
dracolage attendu par l'immense majorité
des associations a aussi fait l'objet
d'une recommandation de la Commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme la CNCDH selon laquelle la
convention de 2005 comme le droit pénal
français prévoit que les victimes de
traite ou d'exploitation doivent être
exonéré de responsabilité pénale dès
lors qu'elles ont adopté un comportement
illicite sous la contrainte la CNCDH
rappelle avec raison que les victimes de
traite ou d'exploitation contraintes à
commettre des crimes ou des déliss
doivent être considérés avant avant tout
comme des victimes de délinquences
forcées et doivent être exonérés de
responsabilité pénale pour avoir commis
de tels faits comme il invite d'ailleurs
l'article 6 du protocole de Palerme la
prostitution parce qu'elle s'inscrit
toujours dans un rapport de domination
le plus souvent la domination masculine
de violence et d'humiliation ne doit
plus être considéré comme une question
marginale cette PPL a le mérite de poser
le problème mais elle ne répond pas à
l'urgence et à l'ampleur de la situation
comme l'a rappelé d'ailleurs la
rapporteur Virginie Cless les réponses à
la prostitution doivent se faire sur le
fond dans le cadre d'une loi globale qui
traite au moins trois volets la société
le client et la personne prostituée pour
les groupes le groupe CRC auquel
j'appartiens la prostitution n'est pas
un métier mais une violence et nous
partageons le travail d'uni qui non
seulement est sur le terrain mais est
force de proposition nous avions
d'ailleurs déposer une PPL en 2010 qui
outre la suppression du délit dracollage
prévoyait différentes mesures sur la
sensibilité la sensibilisation la
responsabilisation des clients
l'éducation la prévention ainsi que des
mesures sociales en direction des
personnes prostituées afin de les
accompagner leur permettre de sortir du
système prostiueur on le voit la
prostitution mérite un grand débat car
selon la réponse qu'on y apporte mes
chers collègues elle dit beaucoup sur le
projet de société que l'on porte un
projet aliénant ou un projet
émancipateur c'est ce qui plaide en
faveur d'une loi globale exprimé par 53
associations regroupées au sein du
collectif abolition 2012 pour elle
l'abrogation du délit dracollage ne
suffit pas et n'efface pas les logiques
contradictoires voir les approches
divergentes qui peuvent exister sur la
question de la prostitution entre pour
le dire vite abolliitionniste et
réglementariste alors que nous sommes en
2013 il est terrible de constater que la
prostitution est toujours justifié comme
étant un mal nécessaire un rempart
contre le viol un remède à la misère
sexuelle d'une certaine catégorie
d'hommes mais la la réalité tout autre
la prostitution ne fait pas baisser le
nombre de viols au contraire le Nevada
État américain qui a légalisé la
prostitution affiche le taux le plus
élevé de viol de tous les États-Unis
c'est la démonstration que sacrifier des
personnes pour prétendre protéger les
autres est une idée reçue une hypocrisie
une violence institutionnelle qu'il faut
éradiquer nous prenons donc cette PPL
comme une première étape qui doit être
suivie rapidement par une loi glal pour
conforter les associations pour trouver
des réponses aux situations vécues par
celles et ceux que l'ont prostitué pour
notre part nous considérons le rapport
d'information de nos collègues Daniel
Bousquet et guigeau froid qui s'appuie
sur le travail d'association de terrain
sur l'intervention reconnue
d'organisations et d'élus politiques
dont les communistes comme une référence
avec 30 recommandations pour une
politique globale cohérente et
respectueuse de l'engagement
abolliitionniste de la France il y a
matière mais chers collègues à légiférer
et apporter une réponse globale à la
prostitution les interventions des deux
ministres madame Christian tobira et
Najad valauelkassem me semble tout à
fait aller dans ce sens et c'est un
point d'appui extrêmement positif je
vous
remercie merci Madame Cohen la parole
est à Chantal joanau du groupe udiuc
pour 8
minutes
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres mes chers
collègues je suis clairement
abolitionniste et je le revendique comme
tel je éradiquer toutes les règles qui
permettent de maintenir le système
prostitutionnel mais qu'est-ce que j'ai
pas entendu alors pas en public parce
qu'en général on fait très attention
plutôt des chuchotements discrets dans
des couloirs comme vous c'est le plus
vieux métier du monde bah oui regardez
donc il y a pas un seul p pays qui a
réussi à éradiquer la prostitution mais
je pourrais même répondre qu'il y a pas
un seul pays qui a réussi à éradiquer
les violences faites aux femmes et pas
un qui a réussi à éradiquer la
pédophilie est-ce que ça fait pour
autant des actes tolérables on me dit
aussi à ça on entend c'est un mal
nécessaire et oui mesdames il faut se
sacrifier pour assouvir
lesirrépressibles besoins sexuel de
certains mais la violence sexuelle n'est
pas un besoin la violence sexuelle c'est
une pathologie et la prostitution n'est
pas un commerce c'est une exploitation
sexuelle 3è discours soyez libéral c'est
vrai que ça va bien à droite
laissons-leur la liberté d'être
travailleuse du sexe et on nous dit
gardez-vous de la moralisation certes ça
c'est la théorie mais la réalité c'est
quoi la réalité c'est pour moins de 5
peut-être 10 àons soyant large 10 % qui
vont choisir cette vie il y a 90 % pour
qui c'est de la violence ce sont des
viols c'est une exploitation et les
chiffres qui ont été cités tout à
l'heure les chiffres de Médecins du
Monde les chiffres de Ligas sont très
clair sur ce sujet c'est un business
mafieux et probablement le deuxième le
plus rentable derrière le trafic d'armes
mais finalement tout ça nous le savons
et le client l'honnête client parce
qu'ils sont nombreux les clients madame
clè un Français sur 5 dit avoir eu une
relation sexuelle tarifée ce client il
se bouche le nez ferme les yeux ferme
les oreilles comme les petits singes
pourquoi peut-être parce que dans 80 90
% des cas ce sont des femmes ce sont des
femmes immigrées en situation illégale
ou alors des homosexuels ou alors des
transsexuels finalement peut-être des
personnes qui pour certains n'auraient
pas le même droit à l'humanité donc le
même droit à la dignité que les autres
et c'est ça qui me choque profondément
alors aujourd'hui vraiment faire
attention de ne pas donner de mauvais
signaux je suis d'accord avec l'objectif
central et le principe central qui est
d'abolir le délit de racolage passif
institué en demi droit et je le dis avec
d'autant plus de sincérité que j'ai
écrit ces discours mais avec une vraie
sincérité à l'époque qui était un
système théoriquement équilibré entre
ces dispositions et des mesures de
protection pour les femmes pour les
prostituées qui dénoncerai leur prox net
la réalité c'est que ça n'a pas été
appliqué comme tel que ces mesures sont
restées dans la plupart des cas lettre
morte pour des raisons diverse pas par
malveillance des services de de police
et que ce délit n'a pas permis
d'accroître les procédures contre les
proxénet à l'inverse la situation des
personnes prostituées s'est aggravée
puisqu'elles ont dû s'éloigner des des
lieux publics tandis que les clients eux
ont pu continuer à faire leur marché
avec leur bonne
conscience deè conviction nous ne devons
pas traiter isolément l'abolition de ce
délit ça a été rappelé par plusieurs moi
je vous dis j'ai une crainte une énorme
crainte mesdames les ministres une fois
ces dispositions passées que se
passera-t-il est-ce qu'on va oublier la
suite est-ce qu'on aura le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout est-ce qu'on aura
laissé comme seul message un
contremessage finalement dans l'esprit
de certains pas le nôtre mais la manière
dont il pourrait être lu un allègement
des
mesures alors pourquoi ne pas attendre
simplement la fin de l'année notre
rapport avec Monsieur gofoi il sera prêt
au mois de septembre idem pour la
délégation au droits des femmes même
avant le rapport de l'Assemblée
nationale il est prêt on a un énorme
travail qui a été fait avec Monsieur
geoffroid et avec Madame Bousquet un
énorme travail on connaît le
sujet troème conviction je ne crois pas
du tout qu'il soit opportun de remplacer
l'abolition l'abrogation de ce délit par
une contravention pourquoi parce qu'on
continue à faire peser la responsabilité
sur les victimes et pas sur les est
coupable et la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme sur
ce sujet est très claire il nous faut
pas de droit d'exception parce que la
prostitution est une exploitation
sexuelle faut tordre le coup au mythes
d'Adam et ve c'est pas parce qu'il y a
des prostituées sur la rue qu'il y a des
client c'est plutôt dans l'autre sens
que ça se joue et surtout n'envoyons pas
un message toujours le même le client de
la prostitution est un homme
respectable tandis que la victime elle
serait coupable si on veut vraiment
vraiment éradiquer ces réseaux on
s'appuie texto texto sur la résolution
qui a été votée à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale en décembre 2011
qui propose la responsabilisation donc
la culpabilisation du client mais
également la protection des prtitués
parce que malheureusement notre
législation n'est pas exactement la même
qu'en Italie et j'ai pas mal
d'amendements sur le sur le sujet et 4è
message que je voudrais vous transmettre
je m'inscris dans la ligée de toutes les
personnes qui sont intervenues en
réalité il y a pas vraiment ici de de
politisation et de divergence de fond ne
nous trompons pas de messagees
n'envoyons pas un mauvais message à la
société les réseaux nous regardent ça
c'est sûr il nous regardent très
attentivement ils sont très intelligents
mais surtout qu'est-ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui la le développement de la
prostitution
étudiante pour des raisons liées à la
précarité et parce que la tarification
des rapports sexuels pour certains n'est
plus un problème ce qui est extrêmement
préoccupant la prostitution sur Internet
extrêmement préoccupante donc ne
banalis banalisons pas le sujet lutter
contre l'exploitation sexuelle ça n'est
pas moraliser la société c'est lutter
contre l'exploitation sexuelle ni plus
ni moins et quand une grande marque de
luxe parce que ça je vais pas le laisser
passer quand une grande marque de luxe
n'est-ce pas Laurence fait l'apologie de
la prostitution pour vendre sa dernière
collection faut pas laisser passer c'est
pas àodin c'est pas Ain il franchisse la
ligne rouge alors si mes amendements ne
sont pas adoptés je voterai pas ce texte
mais je voterai pas contre je
m'abstiendrait parce que j'estime que
voter cette seule disposition pourrait
être un mauvais message je veux juste
rappeler que tout le monde a voté à
l'unanimité et saluer la proposition de
résolution à l'Assemblée nationale en
décembre 2011 qui réaffirmait notre
position abolitionniste et la
responsabilité du client on a de quoi
agir on doit être à la hauteur de notre
conscience éthique j'ai bien noté cette
phrase je l'aime beaucoup donc ma seule
question madame les ministre irrez-vous
jusqu'au bout aurez-vous le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout d'inverser la
charge de la preuve et de faire peser la
culpabilité et la responsabilité non
seulement sur les proxénet mais aussi
sur les clients de la prostitution et je
vous
remercie merci madame Joan la parole est
à Stéphane Mazard du RDSE pour 6 minutes
oui madame le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues le 13
novembre 2002 le ministre de l'Intérieur
de l'époque chargé de défendre le projet
de loi pour la sécurité intérieure
déclaré dans c hémicyle la création du
délit de racolage passif était destinée
à protéger les personnes prostituées
ajoutant même l'argument est lumineux d'
d'Assens simplicité pour simple que soit
cet argument pour ne pas dire simpliste
nous ne pouvons que constater disant
plus tard que les objectifs n'ont pas
été atteints et bien au contraire il
faut se souvenir que la loi du 18 mars
2003 avait été débatue dans un contexte
particulier où le sentiment dit
d'insécurité réel ou ressenti est
ébrandi comme un totem pour justifier un
durcissement de notre droit pénal sans
autre rapproche que celle de la
répression il s'agissait déjà
d'appliquer une méthode qui hélas fit
floresse par la suite à savoir répondre
par une loi un fait divers ou encore
légiférer non pas par la raison mais par
l'émotion nous savons à quel point cette
façon d'élaborer notre droit est
inefficace et que ce soit pour lutter
contre les réseaux de prostitution ou
pour lutter contre les autres
infractions la situation de la
prostitution dans notre pays est
complexe à appréhender
dans la mesure où les formes mêmes de la
prostitution sont multiples en
particulier depuis l'explosion
d'Internet le nombre de personnes
prostituées est d'ailleurs sujet à débat
selon l'Office central pour la
répression de la traite des êtres
humains il y aurait aujourd'hui entre
18000 et 20000 personnes prostitué dans
notre pays un chiffre contesté par le
Syndicat du travail sexuel qui lui
l'estimeme le plus proche de 300000
personnes dans tous les cas ces
personnes et cela a été dit sont des
personnes souvent d'origine étrangère et
en tout cas victime de réseau criminels
le racollage passif a été incriminé par
notre droit en 1939 avant d'être
délectualisé par la loi Marth Richard de
1946 ramené à une simple contravention
en 1958 il fut supprimé en 94 et ce en
raison de l'imprécision de ses éléments
constitutifs qui rendaient en pratique
la poursuite de ce délit impossible le
réétablissement de ce délit en 2003 ne
s'est pas accompagné des outils
juridiques permettant de lutter
efficacement contre les réseaux mafieux
de prostitution apparus dans les années
90 le postulat de départ était plutôt de
vider la voie publique des personnes
prostituées affichant un comportement
considéré alors comme outrancier ou
dérangeant et ainsi faire comme si la
prostitution avait été éradiqué puisque
désormais rendu
invisible certes la diminution de la
visibilité de la prostitution sur la
voie publique a été patente dans les
deux premières années mais ce constat
s'est rapidement inversé dès lors que le
nombre de personnes mises en cause et le
taux de poursuite non' cessé de
diminuer le nombre de condamnations pour
accollage passif c'est lui effondré
passant de000 condamnation en 2005 à 206
en 2009 la grande majorité des peines
prononcées sont désormais des amendes
tandis qu'en 2009 seul 30 cas ont abouti
à une peine d'emprisonnement dont la
grande majorité a sorti d'un surcis on
constate aujourd'hui que les parquets
cela a été dit par Madame learde desau
utilise de façon presque systématique
les alternatives aux poursuite pénal
comme le rappel à la loi mes chers
collègues on ne résout pas un problème
social comme le sort des personnes
prostituées exploitées simplement en le
mettant hors de Pée de vue le rapport
d'information sur la situation de la
prostitution d'avril 2011 de notre
collègue député guisau frroid pourtant
membre de l'ancienne majorité dresse un
bilan accablant du délit de raccolage
passif depuis sa mise en place bien à
rebour de l'intention initiale du
législateur ce délit a engendré des
effets pervers qui n'ont fait
globalement qu'aggraver la situation des
personnes concernées
comme cela a déjà été dit la répression
du racolage passif n'a fait que déplacer
les lieux de prostitution sans effet
réel sur le niveau des activité vers les
zones périurbaines où les personnes
prostituées se retrouvent davantage
exposées à des risques d'agression de
sur croix le statut de délinquante dont
sont àublé désormais ces personnes les
places en situation de fragilité et
d'infériorité face au clients ou au
proxénet qui exerce sur elle chantage et
menace il en résulte que l'effet le plus
notable a été le renforcement de
l'influence des réseaux de proxenet en
effet la fragilisation des personnes
prostituées notamment si elles sont
rentrées de façon clandestine sur le
territoire français en contractant
souvent une dette de passage les oblige
à se placer sous la dépendance de
proxenet enfin on ne peut naturellement
passer sous silence les grandes
difficultés d'accès aux soins et les
conditions d'hygiène dramatiques dont
ptissent ces personnes je tiens
d'ailleurs ici à saluer le rôle des
associations qui œuvrent dans un
contexte difficile pour faire pass des
messages de prévention et assurer une
prise en charge sanitaire et sociale
indispensable madame la ministre madame
les ministres vous avez annoncé la
présentation prochaine d'un projet de
loi sur la prostitution les membres de
mon groupe s'en réjouissent car c'est
bien une politique globale des pouvoirs
publics qu' convient aujourd'hui de
fixer une politique bien sûr de lutte
contre les réseaux d'exploitation des
personnes prostituées mais cela a été
dit également aussi de meilleure prise
en charge sanitaire et sociale de ces
mêmes personnes la seule abrogation du
dé de racollage passif pour
indispensable qu'elle soit ne peut
constituer une fait en soi comme le
démontrre nos débats il est d'ailleurs
significatif que 53 associations de
soutien aux personnes prostituées se soi
prononcé contre le présent texte
estimant que l'abrogation seule du délit
de racolage ne règlera aucunement la
question de la précarisation des
personnes prostituées au contraire
toujours selon ces associations elle
risquerait de fragiliser le travail
visant à reconnaître la violence que
constitue la prostiut
la réflexion doit donc se poursuivre et
je pense en particulier à la question de
la pénalisation des clients question
délicate qu'il est en tout cas prématuré
de trancher ici et maintenant pour notre
part nous sommes conscients que
l'immense majorité des personnes
prostituées sont d'abord des victimes
notre groupe approuvera donc ce texte
pour envoyer un signal politique fort et
rapide et conformément aux positions qui
avait déjà été celle du Parti radical de
gauche en 2003 qui s'était opposé à
l'instauration du déit de racollage
passif
mais nous attendons et cela a été dit
surtout que le gouvernement se mobilise
sur cette question pour apporter une
réponse globale cohérente et plus
protectrice de la dignité des personnes
prostituées vous savez que vous pourrez
compter sur la représentation nationale
et nous savons nous que nous pourrons
compter mesdam ministre sur votre
détermination merci Monsieur Mazar la
parole est à André gatolin du groupe
écologiste pour 6 minutes
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et dont ma
collègue Esther Benbassa et l'auteur ne
poursuit qu'un seul objectif celui
d'abruger un délit inutile et efficace
inefficace le délit de racolage public
si certains ont pu considérer que cette
proposition de loi était examinée dans
la précipitation il nous semble au
contraire que les 10 années d'existence
de ce délit ont permis d'en dresser un
bilan et que les auditions menées par
notre collègue Virgine Cless ont montré
qu'au-delà des considérations
idéologique ou politique le consensus
existe autour de la nécessité d'abreuger
ce délit je dirais même mes chers
collègues qu'il y a urgence à le faire
certains de mes collègues l'ont rappelé
le dél de recolage est é instauré par la
loi pour la sécurité intérieure du 18
mars 2003 au moment de son adoption
cette disposition poursuivait deux
objectif d'abord répondre aux demandes
des riverins en matière de nuisance et
ensuite lutter contre la traite et les
réseaux de proxénétisme il ne s'agit pas
ici et maintenant d'engager le débat sur
la prostitution en général ou de faire
s'affronter partisans de l'abolition et
partisan de la réglementation vous le
savez mes chers collègues les
écologistes sont j' par nature ceux qui
portent le combat contre la
marchandisation du vivant de l'humain et
des corps notre position dans ce débat
Paron d'un simplement d'un constat loin
de remplir les objectifs précités cette
disposition de 2003 a causé des ravage
en terme de santé publique et de
sécurité des personnes prostituées et il
s'agit d'en tirer les conclusions qu'il
s'imposent les hommes et les femmes qui
se prostituent dans notre pays sont en
danger par peort de se voir arrêter
placé en garde à vue et pour nombre
d'entre elles reconduite à la frontière
les personnes prostituées ont été
amenées à s'isoler et à se marginaliser
ou à être marginalisé de plus en plus
chassé de leur lieu habituel de
prostitution elles ont été contraintes
d'exercé dans des conditions sanitaires
et sécuritaires déplorables l'effet réel
de la loi de 2003 a été de faire passer
la prostitution du stade visible de
l'espace public au stade invisible
souterrain surprécarisé et toujours plus
associé à certaines pratiques
criminelles trafi en tout genre violence
physique répéter et cetera je voudrais
m'arrêter un instant pour illustrer
devant vous cette problématique de
l'invisibilité qui entoure actuellement
la prostitution en France les données
quantitatives dont nous disposons à ce
sujet sont rares et peu fiables elles
conduisent à sous-évaluer totalement
l'ampleur du phénomène de la
prostitution dans notre pays en France
le nombre de prostitué est évalué
environ 20000 personnes quand en
Allemagne les estimations faites à ce
sujet parlent de 400000
prostituées concernant les clien de la
prostitution ceci serait selon les dir
des enquêtes par sondage et réalisé sur
une base déclarative d'environ 500000
clients par année notre pays serait donc
en la matière particulièrement vertueux
ou alors nos concitoyen particulièrement
honteux et peu sincère à ce sujet j'opte
plutôt pour la deè solution toujours
selon ces chiffres et en tenant compte
d'une fréquence moyenne et plausible de
trois axes sexuels tarifés par client et
par an cela signifierait que les 20000
prostituées de notre pays effectueraient
en moyenne dire plus de 5 actes sexuel
tarifé par mois le simple bon sens
économique soulligne à lui seul le
caractère absolument farfelu des données
statistiques à notre
disposition plus sérieusement et de
manière malheureusement plus dramatique
encore l'isolement et la marginalisation
accrue depuis 2003 ont eu pour effet de
rendre les personnes prostituées plus
vulnérables et moins à même de négocier
le port du préservatif il a également
conduit de nombreuses personnes
prostituées à exercer sur Internet dans
un isolement souvent propice aux
agressions dans le même sens toutes les
associations de terrain qui viennent en
aide aux prostitué et qui sont souvent
le seul applui pour celles et ceux qui
veulent s'en sortir ont constaté
qu'elles avaient plus difficilement
accès au lieux de prostitution et que
leur action s'en trouvait largement
entravé selon ces associations le nombre
de personnes infectées par le VIH et les
autres infecction sexuellement
transmissible aurait significativement
augmenté depuis l'application de la loi
la délictualisation du racolage a
également eu un effet stigmatisant
dévastateur alors que notre droit ne
pénalise pas la prostitution c'est les
ceux qui la pratiquent sont considérés
comme des délinquants et peuvent être
placés en garde à vue dans des
conditions souvent
déplorable on a alors peine à croire
ceux qui soutiennent que cette
disposition est un outil de lutte
efficace contre la traite des êtres
humains et les réseaux de proxénétisme
suivant le rapport de ma collègue
Virginie Cless les statistiques montrent
l'absence de lien évident entre la
création du délit dracolage et une
augmentation du nombre de condamnations
pour proxénétisme quant au problème liés
aux nuisances causées par la présence de
nombreuses personnes prostituées dans
certains quartiers il convient de
rappeler qu'il existe dans notre droit
des contraventions pour exhibition
sexuelle et trouble à l'ordre public qui
devrait suffire 10 ans après l'adoption
de ce texte le le constat est donc sans
appel le déliis de racolage public n'a
aidé aucune personnes prostituées il a
échoué à protéger les victimes de la
traite il n'a eu que très peu d'effets
dans la lutte contre les réseaux je veux
le redire notre proposition de loi
aujourd'hui ne se place pas sur le
terrain de l'idéologie et nous nous
réjou il s qu'un travail de réflexion
plus large va prochainement être engagé
sur la question sur tous ces aspects qui
devront être envisagés ce sont la
prévention les soins l'accès au droit
l'insertion qui devront être étudiés le
travail permettra alors à tous de
s'exprimer et d'être entendu chacun
pourra faire valoir sa position et le et
le débat promet d'être passionnant en
l'état et devant l'urgence de la
situation sinire et sociale de la
prostitution nous n'en sommes pas encore
là nous en sommes simplement aujourd'hui
pour paraphraser Albert Camu à chercher
à sauver les corps madame la ministre
des Droits de la Femme je ne doute pas
de votre engagement je sais que le
travail a déjà commencé mais cette
répression des personnes prostituées n'a
que trop duré et il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'y mettre un terme je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Joë garam de
l'UMP pour 8
minutes
vous avez la parole chers
collègues monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres chers collègues pardon
madame la Présidente pardonnez-moi
excusez-moi je suis en plein jet
lag la prostitution a toujours pris des
formes diverse elle est plus ou moins
apparente elle est plus ou moins
consentie mais toujours elle tend vers
un même l effacer des individus tout ce
qui fait appel à leur humanité pour
faire de la victime un objet et du
client un consommateur finalement dans
sa forme la plus structurée la
prostitution n'est rien d'autre que de
l'esclavagisme où les prostitués hommes
et femmes sont réduits à l'obéissance
par des procédés divers tromperie
corruption violence contrainte menace
privation de liberté et ce dans un seul
objectif s'enrichir par l'exploitation
mercantile des vises de notre société
par ailleurs et comme ce fut le cas pour
la traite des esclaves nous faisons face
à un réseau international tentaculaire
dont le bétail j'utilise ici à dessin le
vocabulaire du milieu pour que l'on
comprenne bien à quel marché crapuleux
on a à faire donc le bétail disais-je
provient d'Europe de l'Est du Maghreb
d'Afrique noire ainsi nous avons tous
conscience ici que la prostitution est
une tragédie pour tous les défenseurs de
la dignité humaine et que par conséquent
à chaque fois que dans ce domaine les
pouvoirs publics reculent c'est en même
temps toute l'humanité qui régresse le
droit international partage d'ailleurs
ce constat puisque l'Organisation des
Nations unies par le biaet de son
assemblée générale a procédé à
l'adoption le 15 novembre 2000 d'une
Convention contre la criminalité
transnationale qui condamne la traite
des êtres humains et au minimum
l'exploitation de la prostitution
d'autruie ou d'autres formes
d'exploitation sexuelle cette position
est également celle retenue par le
Conseil de l'Europe dans la convention
sur la lutte contre la traite des êtres
humains adoptée le 16 mai 2005 ainsi
madame ben Bassa je crois que nous
partageons le diagnostic de ce fléo
malheureusement nos réflexions emprunent
deux chemins bien différents au terme
desquels nous établissons des
conclusions qui ne peuvent se rejoindre
sur le fond voilà ce qui nous oppose
vous souhaitez abroger ce texte parce
que vous le jugez inefficace à la i de
nombreux rapports vous dites que je cite
pour l'année 2009 2315 personnes ont été
mises en cause pour rolage actif et
passif seulement 465 ont été mis en
cause pour proxénétisme et proxénétisme
aggravé et aucune d'entre elles n'a été
condamné quant au mécanisme prévoyant de
régulariser des victimes du proxénétisme
en échange de leurs témoignage ce sont
seulement 79 personnes qui en ont
bénéficié et en conclusion vous retenez
alors que la législation actuelle a
échoué tant dans sa mission de
protection des victimes du proxénétisme
que dans la lutte menée contre les
réseaux je ne reviens pas sur les
conditions de garde à vue que vous
estimez problématique depuis la loi du
14 avril 2011 de nombreuses réformes ont
été adoptées afin d'améliorer d'encadré
l'exécution de la procédure de garde à
vue depuis nous sommes en parfait accord
avec la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme et sur la base de ces mêmes
données je crois pouvoir établir
d'autres conclusions qui ne me semblent
pas moins fond
le faible taux de mise en cause dans les
affaires de racolage passif et actif
2315 personnes ne signifie pas que ce
phénomène est dérisoire mais au
contraire qu'il est bien plus insidieux
et difficile à identifier qu'on ne
l'imagine dans un dossier du magazine
histoire de janvier 2013 consacré à la
prostitution nombre de prostitué hommes
ou femmes explique que ce qui les a
conduit à s' dononner à cette ce qui les
a conduit à s'adonner à cette pratique
ainsi un courser de 17 ans expliquait
qu'avec plus de 5000 euros par semaine
lui qui était fénéant avait trouvé un
moyen facile de gagner de l'argent le
Nouvel Observateur faisait d'ailleurs
état de ce phénomè lorsqu'il évoquait
dans un article en date du 12 novembre
2012 les nouveaux visages de la
prostitution des jeunes à Paris il
constater l'augmentation des phénomènes
préprostitutionnels qui poussent un
nombre croissant de jeunes à échanger
des faveurs sexuels contre des moyens de
subsistance foyer alimentair